DARKEST SPOTS AT THE PARK.
A BIG
>> IF IT IS ALONG THE BOARDS, AR
COME BACK PRETTYHERE, REALLY
NOWHERE NEAR THE
MENTAL TOUGHNESS RIGHT HERE.
YOU HAVE ONE, DON'T
FROM GERMANY, ROOKIE, FORMER SIX
OVERHAT
MANY TALK ABOUT WITH THE KINGS.
"OUR SPEED HAS
HOURS BEFORE IT WAS SCHEDULED TO
PLAY SONIC TAKE PLACE.
THEY FACE THE DUCKS
DREW DOUGHTY.
A DIVING PLAY TO GET, THAT ONE E
TRYING TO GO FOR THE GOAL LINE.
ANGLES IT TO DURZI.
FIVE SECONDS LEFT IN THE LOW MYD
"YOU'VE GOT TO TAKE THE PARK TO
GOALTENDER.
DOES NOT WASTE MY TIME BRAKE
LIGHT, AND CAL PETERSEN SEEING
HIS FIRST SHOT OF THE NIGHT,
HE.
NO CHANCE.
CREDIT
ROY,
LOOSE PUCK PICKED OUT AGAIN BY .
SHOT, BIG REBOUND FAKES TWICE, S
DRIVE.
LOOKING FOR THE BACK DOOR, LOOSE
PUCK, SHIMMY SHAKE.
GOING ONE WAY, GO BACKLL SWING .
SHOULDN'T HAVE MORE THAN A TWO
GOLD GLOVED BY
NEDELJKOVIC.
HE TAKES
PRESSURE ON.
SAVED TWICE.
FIRST ON THE DRIVE FOR THE HIGH
SLOT.
FROM DRIVING TO THE NET! LARKIN.
WILL ROLL THE PARK AHEAD.
ADRIAN KEMPE SHORTHANDED, IT'S .
THOSE SHOTS OFF GOAL, AFTER THE
FRANCHISE RECORD SETTING 27 IN
SAVE MOORE WAS ASKED ABOUT HIS
TEAMMATES.
TOUCH PASS.
BIG SAVE OFF THE
[TRAIN HORN]
THAT WILL BE THE DAGGER, WITHHHD